Let's go through an example. You and your friends want to go out to eat. But
you don't want to pay a lot. There are two areas of town you're thinking about,
Gettysburg and Wilma. You look online and find the average meal prices at 18
restaurants in Gettsyburg and 14 restaurants in Wilma. The link to these
average prices at all these restaurants is at the bottom. You want to know if
statistically there's a significant difference between the meal prices in each
of these two areas of town. Therefore your null hypothesis is that they're not
statistically different. And your alternative is that they are. This is a
non-directional test. To compare these two samples what do you need to know?
Should we know the population mean for food prices at all restaurants in
Gettysburg and Wilma. The average of each sample. The population standard
deviations. The size of each sample. Or finally the sample standard deviations.